on this episode India comes back
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 217 of the askgaryvee
show
feel like we're in a 215 a 2015 zone
were like we're actually doing shows day
in and day out and there's no other
characters on the set and India is back
which I think makes everybody very happy
me especially it's good to see you get a
good fourth of July nice to hear I
figure I finished episode was really
good but I was zoned in you didn't watch
it
they were like shaking your wives
because I was like oh god they're doing
like I was like the questions I think
they use the wrong part of the dog
you're like Horry uh awesome
alright India I've missed this very much
yeah once last let me think we did this
that's a good normal like a normal
episode where we got to do our little
thing here why lose like a while yeah
all right you ready yes ready
so let's into the show Oh like riding a
bike ah like riding a bike is this a
true fact yes you this is a little fun
fact AJ does not know how to ride a bike
though he's I think he's learning this
summer I have to ping him I haven't
heard anything so I still don't think my
brother who's 29 years old knows how to
ride a bike from outdoor Abdur adore ass
if you're starting from scratch what
metrics would you look at to determine
success uh if you're starting from
scratch what metrics would you look at
in measuring success yes uh money in and
profit post money in this is and I'm
actually making a joke but I'm being
serious it's so funny
I just had a business meeting I think a
lot of people have metrics for the sake
of metrics marketing for the sake of
marketing if you have a business the
only metric that you should be paying
attention to is your top-line revenue
and your profit at the end of the day
that can afford to pay your costs that
are driving your business now if you're
very very early on you want to see
action but I think the reason I'm
jumping on this question is we now live
in a culture where so many people think
the following which is they've been
affected by Twitter Instagram Facebook
and snapchat if you get tens of millions
of followers it doesn't matter that you
don't make money you eventually become a
billionaire the problem is that works
for seven companies that is not the norm
most people try to and this is what's
going to happen over the next decade my
friends you will see an over the next
three years you'll see enormous amount
of companies that went and tried to get
ten thousand a hundred thousand a
million users didn't get there weren't
the hot product the unicorn the
once-in-a-generation business the
once-in-a-generation business and they
ran out of money and then you go out of
business so what I really want to ground
this first question is in practicality
the only metric a business person should
be understanding is their cash flow
money and money out how do you build
momentum is if we're heading in the
right direction I'm very proud that AJ
and I and the senior leadership that
helped us along the way we built an
actual business here vaynermedia was is
an evaluation vaynermedia's revenue and
profit and I do think that we have
gotten way too into users and mentions
and that the one that bothers me the
most number of followers and we've got
away from what are you doing doing
people have come up to me and they're
like yeah I'm struggling you know like
like I this is actually you know and
Darach you wish me it really hit me
during that one kid coming up to me and
in Colorado and I don't wanna pick on
the kid but like like everybody thinks
that amassing of following on social
media as a business amassing of
following on social media is a platform
for you to create a business on top of a
business is a functioning organization
that sells something that you make
profit in so that you can sustain that
business and grow Joe Joe Joe asks you
say to be ourselves 100% what if you
have a troubled past that you overcame
I did or embrace it listen I mean you
know this is a tough question something
I think a lot about I think I do think
and you've been hearing from your
meditation mental health I think the
next frontier the next 50 years of
society within a business context and
with a society gun-control these other
things we're gonna be talking more and
more about the brain mental health
mental status you know there are people
in this world that come from such tough
beginnings we talk a lot about poverty
and opportunity I think because we talk
about entrepreneurship we don't talk I
don't talk a lot about you know you were
raped as a child your parents were
murdered you know some of these really
extreme difficult things I don't
understand or know what Joe's troubled
past or if he's referring for a friend
or for himself I think we all have
different versions of a trouble pass
like some people would say I got bullied
and that was my trouble fast others
would say I was sexually molested and
that's my short like these all vary and
so Joe I what I would say is I have no
interest in sitting here on a high horse
and deploying generic blanket statements
I think we should be I do think that
being yourself 100% is something that
people are attracted to I think all of
us in the same way that America actually
doesn't hate the crime they hate when
you try to cover it up because we know
that you're not being authentic and
you're trying to trick me I think that's
the same reason we react so well to
people that go very far that owned up to
things that are super transparent that
are willing to go there and so what I
would say is you know you should
challenge yourself to go as far down
that funnel as you can because it is
absolutely an attractive quality that
creates opportunity happiness business
opportunities for one however I don't
think you have to air your dirty laundry
and I do think that there's a lot of
help and and many other things that
people have to do to be able to share
things I do not feel comfortable sitting
here saying yes share your deepest
darkest things because maybe you're not
emotionally ready I don't know you on an
individual basis but I can tell you is
that every day I try to push harder and
exposing more of my thoughts and
exposing more of my truths and exposing
more of my weaknesses and exposing more
of my scars and it's a struggle for me
because that you guys have seen over the
last daily businesses that I don't spend
a lot of time on my weaknesses or my
past
from yesterday's episodes first question
I don't hold grudges I don't have a [ __ ]
list it's because I just don't believe
in containing negativities and so I the
only reason at this point in my life I'm
trying to think about my flaws or my
struggles is I want to give you the
people that have decided to give me your
time I feel a sense of responsibility to
all of you that are giving me your time
how many people are on there right now
for a fifteen hundred of you right now
that on Facebook live I feel a sense of
responsibility that in the middle of the
day or if you're in Europe later day the
fact that right now 1500 of you could be
doing something completely different but
I have been gifted your attention which
i think is the number one asset I'm
trying to challenge myself I'm trying to
challenge myself to expose some of my
weaknesses and things that nature but
it's a real struggle for me you know and
so I'm almost the reverse like like I
can't even like begin to think about my
tough upbringing or different thing
Cubao to bad things like I think about
them I deal with them the reality I
don't dwell on them
I spit them out and I move forward I
think it's a very personal question Joe
I think it's like work-life balance I
don't I don't I don't have any interest
in sitting on this show
trying to force somebody right now that
had a very horrible thing happened to
them and they're gonna write a blog post
about it tomorrow and they weren't
emotionally ready and they can't deal
with the repercussions of putting it out
there that is not my place but I will
say to everybody you know if you can get
there I do think there's a lot of
healthiness to it thanks Annie
Mack yeah it wasn't I mean that's a day
it's a heavy subject matter and I and I
do think that one thing in the evolution
of this show is you know there's a lot
of tactics we can talk about how to use
a filter and this Annette but you know I
you know and it could bore you and it
could become repetitive but I do think
this is a mental game I think life is a
mental game I think it's much more about
the brain than people realize and and I
want to continue to push angles of it
because I think it brings people
happiness
tella
I want to go tactical I'd like to mix it
up Matthew asks how do you create
content as a retailer selling
someone else's brands uh I remember this
one I sent this to you I like this one
because I wanted to go Tac Toe you know
it's so funny talk about the yin and
yang me like I also don't want this to
get too heady and philosophical I want
to go tactical anybody who's a retailer
that's struggling with like wait a
minute
I sell sneakers so am I gonna make Nike
content or adidas content or Under
Armour content and put it out I wonder
who is this again Matthew read it one
more time cuz guys check this out I
think this is interesting how right this
is so interesting as a retailer you sell
somebody else's brand that's the
definition of a retailer unless you're
selling retail your product and your
than you know the Under Armour store
right so I got a kick out of this
question I think it's when people are
looking at the lens the wrong way we
live in a world now where brands are
creating content for themselves at scale
and I wonder if Michael Michael right
Matthew
sir thank you Matt if Matthew is looking
at this wrong because he sees the optics
of brands creating content if it's what
you sell you create content Wine Library
creates content of other brands all the
time because we are a retailer and we're
trying to sell this Pinot Grigio it is
not our Pinot Grigio it is somebody
else's but we're creating content
because we're making margin and we've
chosen in the world of business to be a
retailer Matthew the way you create
content if you are a retailer of other
people's brands is to create content of
other people's brands I you know it's
what you do like if you sell other
people's you know brands you make
content now what you could be asking and
more detailed oriented back to being
practical is you may have to follow
guidelines of a brand when you're
producing content I think you need to be
conscious of putting those brands in a
good light because they're your supplier
and they are more than capable of
discontinuing you selling that product
so you have to be political about what
that is but you also have to find a
for an angle that is your angle from the
brands I think one of those places is
price you know most brands are not going
to price because they know the retailers
are selling things at different prices
so their content in the ecosystem is
more jab oriented branding you could
actually be more in the right hook
business this Pinot Grigio got 90 points
from the Wine Spectator and is on sale
for 1199
so you could you know those are kind of
things a retailer does you could also
create content of that product within
your retail store and so you're showing
it in that environment again another
thing brands won't normally do because
they don't want to lead to being favored
picking a favorite from one retailer to
another so use the advantages you have
that you know the mother ship brand
won't do but you can possibly do and I
think for all of you
now leveling this up back to the theme
of yesterday I'm trying to do that more
in this show I think one I think way too
many people dwell on what they can't do
instead of realizing what they can do
right so focus on the things that you
may make you uniquely you and do the
things that you know that other people
can't do whether that's your partner's
like a supplier in a retailer or that's
your competitors they happen to be in
this state you happen to be a happen to
be in Colorado and you've pretty
mountains use that to your advantage you
know like I can't make Mountain content
here you know I hate mountains blanket
that's such a good recall I wonder how
many people are watching right now
actually know we're talking about good
um DITA you're London's DJ young legend
do you think I should come up with a DJ
named love oh you're like yes have you
seen marshmallow yeah medium world
marshmallow very smart stuff right like
from the whole branding and I mean
you're proud of Tyler
cuz he's cool he knows EDM do you know
Indiana oh did you watch micro L episode
yeah cool pants keep up DJ young legend
asks what advice would 40 year old Gary
give 28 year old
I was trying to remember why I picked
this question I really curated a bunch
of questions by the way by the way I
want to know I'm feeling a renaissance
here so a freshness of not having all
these characters on with me really
looking for more questions a lot of you
have not asked a long time a lot of you
asked often and you know as a matter
fact here's what why you do use the
hashtag askgaryvee but also for the the
old-timers the hustlers that have not
had the luck or the serendipity of
having one of their questions on the
show don't lie because lying is the
devil and I'm going to make Indian team
actually do the homework for all of you
when you ask your next question that you
want a next show which hopefully will be
tomorrow or the next day or what have
you next week whatever do hash tag ask a
review like we do on Twitter or or
Instagram but also then in the copy put
X how many times have you asked for a
question to be on the show and have not
had it so meaning if you ask the
question 43 times but your questions
been on the show don't use the X but if
you are a virgin to the question being
on the show but you've asked 84 times it
might be a nice time to like show up now
there may be a reason you haven't been
picked because you know it could be
people that I just asked crappy
questions talent is a variable you are
bad at asking questions but we're going
to push a little harder and try to get
you on the show we love videos uh DJ
young legend asked 40 and 20 year old
self and again I know a lot of you do
rock you in India probably more so maybe
even Stefan at this point you guys know
me so well that you probably to keep
yourself not bored of filming these
things start answering what you think
I'm going to say and I think you think
I'm going to go down the traditional
path of like hang out with more chicks
have more funds on the weekend all that
that's where I've gone cliche you got a
place we're about to go not a 28 a 22
it's funny you said that maybe that's
why I picked it 28 was very interesting
year for me
it's when I got engaged um I'm gonna
stun everybody right now I would tell
28-year old Gary to work more and I'm
gonna throw you for a loop what a lot of
you don't know about 28 year old Gary
is 28 year old Gary was working 9 to 7
like I'm really
sad that my life went this way here's
what I mean by that from Taz I hustled
as much as I hustled 22 to 32 I work way
more now and to be very honest with you
that stinks
because I have a family and at 22 to 30
or 22 to 28 I'm nobody but myself right
and so what I would tell 28 year old
Gary is in two years you're going to
drive on the highway and you look at
yourself and you're going to say that
you're full of [ __ ] and that you're not
hustling I know that just came out right
and kind of that we just did content
that and so why wait two years in the
same way that 38 year old Gary started
taking care of his health instead of
waiting 240 which was my main plan I
would say the 28 year old Gary hey bro
you're gonna realize in 24 months that
you're not doing the actions it's going
to take you're doing everything right if
you want to be very successful and live
a very nice life and and be rich and all
that but you're nowhere close to
all-time legacy and not even in the same
realm of buying the New York Jets so get
your [ __ ] together and do it now and I
wish I would because that would have
been 224 more months of the hustle
that's executed so much happiness for me
and so you know no question not regret
because I don't look backwards I don't
let negativity but it would be
convenient if I was working 20-hour days
and traveling 22 to 32 verses now when
it's coming out of Misha and Xander and
Lizzy you know it's tough so that's what
I would say I would say hey this is how
it's gonna play out you might as well
get a couple more years and now because
if I stop going extreme and by the way
and this is a fun thing for you guys
here I am absolutely in the early stages
in my own brain of not traveling to the
level that I've been traveling you know
the kids are now seven and four just a
lot more functions they're just I want
to spend more time with them these are
formative years like so you know if I
let's say I decide to like really slow
it down a significant level at 43 let's
say that's my prediction right now you
know well then I could you know 28 could
have made that 41 it's kind of how I
think about it it's all just math
numbers and you know everybody's gonna
jump in the comments is a different
things of course of course and that's
not wrong but 20 you Gary hustled but us
the way a lot of you hustled pre seeing
dailyvee and snapchat which is you
thought you were the best hustler you
knew and then you got to see how I do it
you're like Jesus and that's who that
guy was and he worked hard and whatever
but he wasn't this guy cool I'm curious
what 60 year-old Gary's gonna say a 40
year old Gary or her you think so do you
think honestly without a joke do you
think like like on a serious kick I'm
actually a little bit nervous this is me
like let's go into like I never speak to
my fears here this could be interesting
I'm not you know I'm very conscious that
it becomes like a speed junkie right
like I don't even know what it would be
like to work 9:00 to 8:00
like like you understand the once in a
blue moon and I walk home and like walk
into my apartment like I'm talking three
times a year during the work days I mean
obviously think holidays and all that
but like to cope to walk tonight to walk
into my apartment at 8:00 p.m.
feels awkward like oh like like I
remember this is not a joke there was
some funny day that happened maybe three
or four months ago when I came home at
9:45 p.m. and I walk in I hear Lizzy in
rooms like what are you doing home so
early and I was like Jesus
like like 9:40 p.m. yard I was like 9:45
is later of enormous amounts of people
there are enormous amount of you that
are watching this right now that will
never come home that late in the history
of your work career you know anyway oh
so uh back to what I was like fearful of
I'm worrying that like like the action
is so intense that like like it's a
detox like I actually already know for
me to cut back what I just alluded to
I'm gonna have to have a detox here like
it didn't take me a lot of time three
four or five that would be some fun
dailyvees I'm like in the corner like
like it's gonna take me six it's gonna
take me six months to like if I want to
come home my my weird intuition is it's
not that I'm gonna come home at seven
it's that I'm going to come home at five
or six spend an hour 90 minutes with the
family and then go back out
it's my intuition that's my main plan
for the next move I think because the
kids are going to go to sleep early
anyway like later you know seven eight
years from now like when they're
actually up to eight ten eleven twelve
that's why I let me say go out you're
not like going out to work you know go
back out right back out to work all
right yeah no sir great Gary V name is
NASA elderly my problem area and this is
my hometown miss I hope English peas
this is awesome I just asked does your
father all of this house house taking
care care oh thank you you're welcome
so many times until my god I mean yeah
be able to make six week and and John
Jodi over our passion one year here in
teachers I'm going to be in the country
this is going to be okay hello can I
imagine the education content you know
what from a lot of you follow me and
you've heard time and time again one
channel one channel don't but my friend
I'm glad you asked this is the nuances
this why this show is so great
I would actually it's funny but I would
do separate channels I'll tell you why
your first place that you established is
so utilitarian Wine Library TV though
about wine though about information
about wine still had a lot to do with my
personality with a Gary which then
allowed me to kind of blend stuff you're
doing hardcore utilitarian education
content what I don't know is how much it
is of you my friend if you know looking
through there you seem very cares
Mattox so if you feel like a lot of
people watch the first thing because of
your charisma then I think you can blend
it in one but if you think they're there
just to learn English and it's a utility
for them you could start having a
schizophrenic issue at hand when you
start showing them the sky timing stuff
what I would say is the following
for you this is why individual advice
matters I would create separate channels
I would use your personal Instagram your
personal Twitter like I think you can
mix them but I would from a YouTube
standpoint I would have them as separate
channels and I would once in a while mix
them in social and maybe even once a
while mix like maybe one video of like
by the way like I would almost call it
by the way bTW this is something else I
do this way it's you know kind of almost
a commercial within your other channels
you can cross pollinate that would be my
strategy what it's pretty lasting banana
yeah Gary
you're not you're not the only one very
fast very fast we might have to have a
competition looks like we're going now
serious oh wait no you don't analyze you
that's great it's great good show good
show
what were the themes of today a question
of the day what wouldn't you tell
yourself if you went back in time 10
years and could give that person advice
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
you